right the gear is essentially the unit
that astronomers use to denote time when
you're measuring things in astronomy
it's useful when the numbers don't come
out too big or too small right it's just
like you know when you somebody ask how
old you are you tend to give you aging
years rather than in seconds just
because you end up with a number that's
sort of ten or twenty or thirty rather
than something that's millions or
billions
it's basically a billion years sort of
the smallest time scale you can see
cosmological things happening in the
universe especially on the scale of
galaxies so we just define units that
are the sort of the natural units to
measure things in and when you're
measuring things to do with the age of
the universe the Giga Year the billion
years is the most natural unit to use
because the universe itself is about 14
billion years old well what one thing is
that a simple garden snail in a gear
that is in 1 billion years would call
around the Earth's circumference about
10 million times so you can imagine it
would take quite a long time for garden
snail to even move short distance but in
a gear it could go around the the earth
10 million times there's already a
number which is are too hard to
understand so when you call it a gig a
year you kind of hide how big it is
because it's you know 13.7 gears and
that sounds like quite a sensible number
so be 13.7 but actually you know you've
hidden all the all the stuff you don't
really have a grasp for in the unit 13.7
billion years and how long's a billion
years it's not something that I have any
real physical field for it do to try to
understand when a gear is is very
difficult it's like anything with with
astronomical units with distances with
times human beings really can't envision
what exactly a gear is if I'm told that
the earth is four billion years old or
for GigE years old then I immediately
put that in the context of knowing that
the universe is 13.7 GigE years old and
so you know the others about 1/3 as old
as the universe so in those kind of
relative terms you can kind of
understand it but then when you sort of
step back and think well how big is a
billion years how big is a year that's
when you really kind of start struggling
to actually have a physical grasp for
what's going on but really understand
what it means it's not something you can
do is something that in fact most
astronomers just tend not to even think
about or worry about after being the
field for actually not very long you
can't really stop and try to think about
what is you know what does a gear what
is what is 100 million light years you
know what are these distances mean what
are these timescales mean because you
really can't imagine what they are from
our daily experiences even our lifetimes
so for example one of the things that's
a very active area of astronomy now one
of the things we study here at
Nottingham
is the formation of galaxies something
that would happen in a gear would be for
example a galaxy merger if two galaxies
smashed together and they form a new
galaxy and that will happen in about a
gear we're slowly pushing back towards
the beginning to understand how galaxies
first started to form but they're still
forming today and in fact you know
galaxies like our own in the Milky Way
it's still changing it's still evolving
in structure so in that sense you know
the formation of a galaxy is something
that takes something comparable to the
lifetime of the universe to happen so is
something that occurs over tens of
billions of years tens of giggy years
you have some cases some stars some
middle mass stars will die in about a
gear but things like our Sun will live
for about ten years and the earth is
about 5kg years currently and will
presumably not live past the sun's age
so it has another 5gb years left so
we're sort of in the middle between this
ten gears and the universe itself is
about thirteen point six seven Giga
years old most other things happen
rather on more the shorter time scales
so the formation of a star for example
will take hundreds of thousands to maybe
a million years to happen so a
thousandth of a gear so it's a tiny
fraction of a gear well another common
unit in astronomy is the mega year which
is my R and that's that's million years
so it's ten to the six years and that's
a very quick timescale and for astronomy
astronomical processes usually take much
longer than a million years and that
gets used sort of geologically if you're
interested in the formation of the
geology of the earth formation of rocks
and so on that happens over those kind
of millions of years timescales
formations of stars can take millions of
years so again that's something you'd
measure in many years but the only one
that really gets commonly used is the
gear the billion years